the election is now 18 days away and
even a charity gala cannot stop the
sniping between Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton they traded barbs at a dinner in
New York that traditionally features the
Republican and Democratic nominees
now this lighthearted atmosphere took a
weird turn
during the speeches but in the end
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump shook
hands something they did not do at their
final debate we were all there last
night Margaret we all know it was really
something to watch front-row seat it
really was something to watch a very
unlikely dinner date for Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump and likely their last
face-to-face meeting before Election Day
it was supposed to be a good-natured
ribbing to raise money for charity but
there were boos after the Republican
nominee went on the attack a veritable
act of God brought Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton together
Hillary accidentally bumped into me and
she very civilly said pardon me let me
talk to you about that after I get into
office the Archbishop of New York got
the two presidential candidates to break
bread and trade jokes people look at the
Statue of Liberty and they see a proud
symbol
Donald looks at the Statue of Liberty
and sees a four
maybe a five if she loses the torch and
tablet and changes her hair the long
tradition of candidates poking fun at
themselves and each other at the New
York charity white tie dinner is meant
to honor politician Al Smith who in 1928
was the first Catholic US presidential
nominee the goodwill did not last long
Hillary believes that it's vital to
deceive the people by having one public
policy the well-heeled crowd booed some
of trumps nastier jabs here she is
tonight in public pretending not to hate
Catholics Trump feigned offense that the
media praised First Lady Michelle
Obama's 2008 convention speech but
criticized Melania for plagiarizing it
my wife Melania gives the exact same
speech and people get on her case and I
don't get it and Clinton nodded to her
habit of avoiding questions from the
press and look at this Dyess we got
Charlie Rose and Maria Bartiromo and
Chris Matthews and Gayle King and Norah
Donald and Katie Couric this counts as a
press conference right
it was all good fun neither of those
candidates is really known for their
sense of humor but by the end of the
night six million dollars had been
raised for impoverished children here in
New York you guys got a show at the end
of the day that's the most important
thing but there were a couple of very
awkward moments where you're trying to
hold your face on straight because that
in that room
they say Charlie you've been there many
times that people are never booed they
said that that was the first time that
anybody had ever been booed on the
podium and it's something - Tunis is not
the tone yeah it's a owner supposed to
be sort of really poking fun yes yes and
about unity about yourself it's supposed
to be more self-deprecating than
anything yeah it was a little